why
[Music]
do we go to therapists now it's because
it's because
people don't have big families now I was
looking at the average kid's like family
size 100 years ago it was five kids
so five kids was the average size so if
you have four siblings okay and two
parents
one of them's bound to give good advice
one of them's bound to be The Peacemaker
of the family and you know now we're
going to strangers where they're going
to the internet to get advice
and it's not necessarily the kid's fault
like I mean I'd say we I don't have a
therapist I go to like I try I did try
therapy for a very short period of time
I was like this I'm getting out
of here are you something to talk about
my problems how is that going to improve
that